This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖尔斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。多少男人随身携带着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。这并不意味着你必须这么做，听听如何艰难地。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在iHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，以艰难的方式学习。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Welcome back to another episode of the podcast. We're glad to have you. Well, I'm glad to have you. It is just me. But thanks for tuning in, especially with this week.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《女友们，相信我，宝贝》。欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。欢迎收听本期播客。很高兴有你陪伴。好吧，很高兴有你收听。今天只有我一个人。但感谢你的收听，特别是对于本周的
week's topic, which is pretty heavy. I feel like I've been saying that about a lot of our episodes recently, but this is one that I really wanted to record this weekend on this day in particular. We're talking about grief. And before we get into it, just some disclaimers, I guess, as we often do at the start of these episodes. Firstly, if you are experiencing grief, if you're having a hard time with the loss of someone, I'm just sending you love. And at the end of this episode, there are some numbers and some websites that you can visit
本周的话题相当沉重。我觉得最近我们的很多节目我都这么说过，但这期节目我真的特别想在这个周末、在今天录制。我们来聊聊悲伤。在开始之前，我想先做一些免责声明，就像我们在这些节目的开头经常做的那样。首先，如果你正在经历悲伤，如果你正艰难地面对某人的离去，我只想向你送去爱。在本期节目的最后，有一些电话号码和网站你可以访问，
that will hopefully help you out during this time. Secondly, more lighthearted note, if you hear the rain outside, it's because it's currently flooding in Sydney. So I wanted to get this episode out regardless, but it might mean that we have a few AMR interruptions of the rain, but it kind of contributes to the theme of this episode, which is grief, the psychology of grief. And yeah, I feel like it's a pretty personal episode. It's a pretty
希望能在此时此刻对你有所帮助。其次，一个比较轻松的话题，如果你听到外面有下雨的声音，那是因为悉尼目前正在发洪水。所以我无论如何都想推出这期节目，但这可能意味着我们会有一些雨声的插曲，但这也算是切合了本期节目的主题，那就是悲伤，悲伤的心理学。是的，我觉得这是一期非常私人的节目。这是一期相当
hard episode to record. I think with a lot of the, yeah, with a lot of the episodes I put out, the main reason why I want to talk about them, you know, like my heartbreak episode, like my my loneliness episode is because that's something I'm going through and something that's really impacting me as a person in my 20s and grief is one of those things and a pretty big thing in my life at the moment. So I'm sure that there are others who might also be experiencing this, have experienced in the past, will experience it in the future as hard as that is. But grief, I'm mainly talking about grief around the death of a loved one, which if you have experienced, I'm so sorry. And if you haven't, I guess it's one of those things.
录制起来很艰难的节目。我想，对于我发布的很多节目，我想要谈论它们的主要原因，你知道的，比如我的心碎节目，比如我的孤独节目，是因为那是我正在经历的事情，也是真正作为我这个20多岁的人在深刻影响着我的事情，而悲伤就是其中之一，也是我目前生活中的一件大事。所以我确信，可能还有其他人也在经历这种情况，过去经历过，未来也会经历，尽管这很难。但我所说的悲伤，主要是指围绕亲人离世的悲伤，如果你经历过，我深表遗憾。如果你没有经历过，我想这也是其中之一。
Death is inevitable in life and grief is one of those emotions, part of the human experience that comes with living and loving. So it's something I really wanted to touch on for a while, especially since, yeah, it's my birthday of someone I. I lost last year. It's the first birthday we've had since out since they've passed. So yeah, a pretty emotional weekend. I didn't get to be with my family this weekend. So grief has been a big part of the last 48 hours, but all part of the human experience, I think, and something that is worthwhile discussing. So just under a year ago, I lost someone who I really loved in my life, someone who was really, really important to me. And the circumstances around that experience and around their passing
死亡是生活中不可避免的一部分，而悲伤则是伴随着生活和爱而产生的、属于人类体验的情感之一。所以我一直很想探讨这个话题，特别是，是的，这是我去年失去的一位故人的生日。这是他们去世后我们过的第一个生日。所以，是的，这是一个非常情绪化的周末。这个周末我没能和家人在一起，所以在过去的48小时里，悲伤占据了很大一部分，但我认为这也是人类体验的一部分，是一个值得探讨的话题。就在不到一年前，我失去了我生命中深爱的人，一个对我来说非常非常重要的人。围绕那次经历以及他们离世的情况，
meant that it was really hard to grieve them. And it has been a bit of a heavy burden since their passing. At the time, I was dating someone, seeing someone who wasn't particularly supportive or very nice to me. So it was really hard to get support from them. It was during a lockdown. So I was away from my family. I was away from, I wasn't able to attend the funeral, which was really, really hard attending a
这意味着为他们哀悼真的很难。自从他们去世以来，这一直是一个有点沉重的负担。当时，我在和一个对我不怎么支持、也不是很好的人约会。所以很难从他们那里得到支持。那是在封城期间。所以我远离了我的家人。我远离了，我无法参加葬礼，通过Zoom参加葬礼真的非常非常难。
funeral over Zoom. And I think only in the past three months after having moved away from where I previously lived, have I really come to terms with the fact that I lost this person and have been able to process it. So if you have lost someone recently, I know it's really, really hard and I know that grief is one of those extremely complicated feelings that is just, it's not linear, it's not easy, it's very complicated and personal, but hopefully this episode gives some structure or kind of psychoeducation around why we feel the way we do when we lose someone. I think it's one of those things where, of course we feel sad, of course we feel heartbroken, but beyond that, it's just so unclear.
我想直到最近三个月，在搬离我以前住的地方之后，我才真正接受了我失去这个人的事实，并能够去处理它。所以如果你最近失去了某人，我知道这真的非常非常难，我也知道悲伤是一种极其复杂的情感，它不是线性的，它并不容易，它是非常复杂和私人的，但希望这一集能为我们失去某人时的感受提供一些结构或心理教育。我认为这是其中一件事，当然我们会感到难过，当然我们会感到心碎，但在那之外，它实在是太模糊了。
why everything just feels so disturbed and confusing. That's the one thing I've noticed about my great fitlet losing this loved one in the past year is that it's really, really nuanced. Some days it's totally fine. I feel blessed. I feel grateful to have known them. I don't feel sad. I know they lived a beautiful life.
为什么一切都显得如此混乱和令人困惑。这是我在过去一年里失去这位挚爱后注意到我的悲伤的一个特点，那就是它真的非常微妙。有些日子完全没问题。我觉得很幸运。我很感激能认识他们。我并不觉得难过。我知道他们过着美丽的生活。
But the next day I, you know, find myself like in tears. The other day I was watching Little Women, the movie with like, Sersha Ronan and Emma Watson, no connection to the person who's passed at all, but I was just like sobbing and I felt so embarrassed, you know, it'd been a year since I, almost a year since I'd lost them, but that's the important thing about grief that I think a lot of us who have experience understand. It's not linear. Some days you're fine, some days you're not. I think the experience of grief is best described as following almost like a wave-like pattern, which does, provide a pretty useful framework, I think, to understand grief and to understand this experience.
但第二天我，你知道的，发现自己泪流满面。前几天我在看电影《小妇人》，就是西尔莎·罗南和艾玛·沃森演的那部，和那个去世的人一点关系也没有，但我就是泣不成声，我觉得好尴尬，你知道的，距离我失去他们已经有一年了，几乎有一年了，但这就是关于悲伤的重要一点，我想我们这些有经验的人都能理解。这不是线性的。有些日子你很好，有些日子你不好。我认为悲伤的体验最好被描述为几乎遵循一种波浪式的模式，这确实，我认为，为理解悲伤和这种体验提供了一个非常有用的框架。
Most people and, you know, family members and other people around me who've lost people at the same time or have lost people in their lives. You know, they also report that, you know, the intensity and frequency of these waves of grief, lessons over time, even though trigger waves, I guess, which, you know, are usually accompanied by things like milestones or birthdays or anniversaries can occur really at any time, even years later, they say that grief never really goes away. You just learn to live with it. And I think that's absolutely true. Triggers as well are such a huge part of the grief process.
大多数人，你知道的，家人以及我周围其他在同一时间失去亲人或生活中失去过亲人的人。你知道，他们也报告说，这些悲伤浪潮的强度和频率随着时间而减弱，尽管触发这些浪潮的因素——通常伴随着里程碑、生日或周年纪念日等事情——确实随时都可能发生，甚至在多年后也是如此，他们说悲伤从未真正消失。你只是学会了与它共存。我认为这绝对是真的。诱发因素也是悲伤过程中非常重要的一部分。
If someone was an important part of your life, there are going to be things every day, every moment that remind you of them, you know, a song, seeing someone who resembles them, just certain seasons, certain days, certain months. And some trigger waves can come out of the blue, but others are anticipated, like I've kind of alluded to, like a significant date. That's why I'm talking about this topic today, a significant date passed in the life of this person, and in the posthumous life, I guess, of this person. And it really brought up a lot of mixed emotions and fears and sadness.
如果某人是你生活中的重要部分，每天、每个时刻都会有事情让你想起他们，一首歌，看到一个长相酷似他们的人，某些特定的季节，特定的日子，特定的月份。有些触发波可能会突如其来，但其他的则是预料之中的，就像我刚才暗示的，比如一个重要的日子。这就是我今天为什么要谈论这个话题的原因，在这个人的生命中，在一个可以说是这个人的身後生命中，一个重要的日子过去了。这确实唤起了许多复杂的感情、恐惧和悲伤。
But I think it's important to emphasize that this wave-like pattern triggers. They're completely normal and not a sign that you're getting worse. In normal grief, the intense symptoms, they normally subside slowly, but can sometimes cause, you know, some of those blues that we're going to talk about. So I guess this is the main crux of the episode. What is grief? How does grief impact us? Why is it important to get our head around how it works?
但我认为重要的是要强调，这种波浪式的模式会触发。它们是完全正常的，并不是你病情加重的迹象。在正常的悲伤中，强烈的症状通常会慢慢消退，但有时确实会导致，你知道的，一些我们将要讨论的忧郁情绪。所以我想这就是这一集的核心所在。什么是悲伤？悲伤是如何影响我们的？为什么围绕它是如何运作的建立概念很重要？
Everyone is going to experience loss in some form or another. So having a good understanding of its timeline of the feelings associated with it, how to best get through it. And just a sense of acceptance, I think, is something I really wanted to talk about. So beginning with some of the basic theories of grief. So there is this idea that following the death or the loss of someone that we really love, grief, that feeling of an intense emotional and, physical reaction that an individual might experience. It follows kind of a U-shaped curve,
每个人都会以这样或那样的形式经历失去。因此，对它的时间线、与之相关的感受、如何最好地度过它有一个很好的理解。我认为，一种接纳感是我真正想谈论的。那么，从悲伤的一些基本理论开始。所以有这样一个观点，在失去我们真正爱的人或某人去世之后，悲伤，那种强烈的情感和身体反应，是个人可能会经历的。它大致呈U形曲线，
moving from, you know, feeling okay, having high energy to the next day feeling pretty hopeless and having low morale. I guess those low points are where we really understand and appreciate our grief. It's that feeling of despair and depression. But the good thing to know is that those moments don't really last forever. We do end up getting back to who we were before, getting back to a point where life is happy and we have energy and the loss is accepted. So that's the real kind of emphasis I want to make throughout this, is that grief is nuanced. It really does impact people in different ways. And not only is grief characterized by deep sadness, but also a really deep and intense yearning to be with someone again, to be with that person that
从，你知道的，感觉还好，精力充沛，到第二天感觉相当绝望，士气低落。我想那些低谷正是我们真正理解和欣赏我们的悲伤的地方。那是绝望和沮丧的感觉。但好消息是，那些时刻并不会永远持续下去。我们最终会回到从前的自己，回到生活幸福、精力充沛、并且接受了失去的状态。所以这就是我贯穿始终真正想强调的重点，那就是悲伤是微妙的。它确实以不同的方式影响着人们。悲伤不仅以深深的悲伤为特征，还伴随着一种非常深切而强烈的渴望，想要再次和某人在一起，和那个
you've lost. It's pretty well known that the death of a loved one is one of the most powerful, important, impactful stresses in everyday life, often causing significant distress to all of those closely connected to the deceased, especially when you don't get the chance to have closure or say goodbye. There's this scale that measures how likely someone is going to experience an episode of mental ill health or stress or depression. And it's like a rating system. And if, you know, a certain event or certain experience has happened to you in the past year, you're more likely to experience, you know, depression or sadness or anxiety. And the highest rated item on that scale is the death of someone close to you. Bereaved individuals, they are the most at risk of
你失去的人。众所周知，亲人的离世是日常生活中最强大、最重要、最具冲击力的压力源之一，通常会给所有与死者密切相关的人带来巨大的痛苦，尤其是当你没有机会获得心灵的抚慰或好好说再见的时候。有一个量表可以衡量一个人经历心理健康问题、压力或抑郁发作的可能性。这就像一个评级系统。如果，你知道的，在过去的一年里，某些事件或某些经历发生在你身上，你更有可能经历，你知道的，抑郁、悲伤或焦虑。而该量表上评分最高的项目就是你亲近之人的离世。丧亲者，他们面临的风险最高，
serious mental health problems like depression, substance abuse, sometimes even an increased risk of suicide. And whilst bereavement, it is a normal human experience. And I would say the majority of us will adapt over time to loss and grief. It does remain an extremely painful period where adjustments can take months, if not years, especially if you don't have the support around you. I know that when my loved one passed away, I couldn't run to family. I couldn't, you know, go and get that closure. And at the time, I didn't have an amazing support network. And that made it a lot harder, but no two people will experience the death of a loved one in the same way. how we express pain depends on a number of factors, including, you know, your personality,
患严重心理健康问题，如抑郁症、药物滥用，有时甚至会增加自杀风险。虽然丧亲之痛是人类正常的经历，而且我想我们大多数人随着时间的推移都会适应失去和悲伤，但它仍然是一个极其痛苦的时期，调整可能需要几个月甚至几年，尤其是当你周围没有支持的时候。我知道当我的挚爱去世时，我无法向家人倾诉。我无法，你知道的，去获得那种慰藉。当时我没有一个了不起的支持网络。这让事情变得更加困难，但没有两个人会以完全相同的方式经历亲人的离世。我们表达痛苦的方式取决于许多因素，包括，你知道的，你的性格，
the circumstances surrounding the death, someone who dies unexpectedly versus someone who dies following prolonged illness. That's really going to impact how much time you had to adjust. And it has, you know, how you experience grief also has something with, something to do with religion, spirituality, the way you see the world, and one of the hardest things of people who are grieving is not really knowing what to expect, especially in the first few months, and whether your experience is crazy. So I thought we'd go through some of the symptoms around grief, some of the common experiences. So the major symptoms or feelings of grief that we feel, they often fall across a few categories, you know, around physical symptoms, cognitive symptoms, emotional, that kind of thing. So I thought it would be important to kind of go through
死亡周围的环境，意外去世与长期患病后去世的人。这真的会影响你有多少时间去适应。而且，你如何体验悲伤也与宗教、灵性、你看待世界的方式有关，对于正在悲伤的人来说，最困难的事情之一就是真的不知道会发生什么，尤其是在前几个月，以及你的经历是否疯狂。所以我想我们应该经历一些围绕悲伤的症状，一些常见的经历。因此，我们感受到的悲伤的主要症状或感觉，它们通常属于几个类别，你知道的，围绕身体症状、认知症状、情感症状等等。所以我觉得有必要经历一下
them about what to expect if you've lost someone recently. So in terms of physical symptoms, there is a physical psychological effect of grief on your body and on how you feel physically. They often resemble the physical symptoms of depression and include things like appetite, loss, difficulty sleeping, I felt really tired, a loss of energy, physical pains, which can often be psychosomatic so you feel pain where there isn't actually an external kind of pressure or external injury, a suppressed immune system, those kind of things. And there's also the things of, you know, like crying and wailing and intense physical agitation. Those experiences, those responses are completely normal. Cognitive symptoms of grief. These often cover how we think and
如果你最近失去了某人，应该期待什么。就身体症状而言，悲伤对你的身体和你的身体感觉有着生理和心理上的影响。它们通常类似于抑郁症的身体症状，包括食欲不振、睡眠困难、我感到非常疲倦、失去精力、身体疼痛，这些通常是心身疾病，所以你会感觉到并不存在实际外部压力或外部损伤的疼痛、免疫系统受抑制，诸如此类的事情。还有一些事情，比如哭泣、号啕大哭和强烈的身体焦虑。这些经历、这些反应是完全正常的。悲伤的认知症状。这些通常涵盖我们在失去亲人后如何思考和
perceive the world following the loss of a loved one. For example, you might feel a sense of dissociation and distance from reality. This is linked to feelings of disbelief concerning the loss. It's really hard to process that someone's there one day and gone the next. So confusion, poor memory, lack of focus, it's totally okay if you're feeling that right now. And if you've felt that before, you're not going crazy, there's nothing wrong with you. Death is misunderstanding. understood, it's confusing, we don't know what happens. So all of those responses to the loss and the death of a loved one is completely normal and really similar to some of those emotional symptoms we might feel as well, like guilt and anger. Anger, that's something I really want to
感知世界。例如，你可能会感到一种与现实的解离感和距离感。这与对失落的不信感有关。很难接受一个人一天还在，转眼就没了的事实。所以困惑、记忆力差、注意力不集中，如果你现在有这种感觉，完全没关系。如果你以前有过这种感觉，你没有疯，你没有任何毛病。死亡是被误解的。它令人困惑，我们不知道会发生什么。所以对失去和亲人离世的所有这些反应都是完全正常的，并且与我们可能感受到的某些情绪症状非常相似，比如内疚和愤怒。愤怒，那是我真的很想
talk about later. Hostility, anxiety, feelings of isolation. I know for me, I didn't want to talk to anyone about it. I didn't want someone to support me. I just wanted to be alone. And these emotions, they rarely occur simultaneously. And they may appear in kind of in phases, the stages of grief, which we'll talk about later. There also are these interpersonal symptoms. The effects of grief can often spill over into the grieving person into someone's relationships with others. Grief is often accompanied by social withdrawal, feelings of distance or resentment towards people around you.
稍后再谈。敌意、焦虑、孤立感。我知道对我和我来说，我不想和任何人谈论这件事。我不想让任何人支持我。我只想一个人待着。这些情绪很少同时出现。它们可能会以某种阶段的形式出现，即悲伤的阶段，我们稍后会讨论。还有这些微观人际关系的症状。悲伤的影响往往会蔓延到悲伤者的其他人际关系中。悲伤往往伴随着社交退缩，对周围人的疏离感或怨恨感。
The resentment is a huge thing. There's no shame in that. But a sense of, you know, you don't understand my loss. You don't know what I'm going through. You haven't had to be through this. I resent you for not understanding what this is like. And that links to lifestyle symptoms. If you're interpersonal and personal relationships are under strain,
怨恨是一件大事。这没什么好羞耻的。但有一种感觉，你知道的，你不理解我的失落。你不知道我正在经历什么。你没有经历过这些。我怨恨你不理解这是什么感觉。这与生活方式的症状有关。如果你的人际关系和个人关系承受着压力，
the rest of your life is probably going to be impacted as well. it's really hard when you are grieving, when you are sad, to perform your daily routines, to do your self-care and to, you know, get involved in activities that you previously found really enjoyable. Everything has kind of changed. Death is one of those things that really jolts us back to the reality and puts us in our place in terms of our role in this world. It's existential and getting up and pushing on with.
你生活的其余部分可能也会受到影响。当你悲伤时，当你难过时，很难维持你的日常琐事，进行你的自我照顾，并且，你知道的，参与你以前觉得非常愉快的活动。一切都变了。死亡是那些真正让我们猛然清醒面对现实，并在我们在这个世界上的角色方面让我们认清自己位置的事情之一。它是存在主义的，并且在经历那次经历后振作起来并继续推进
life following that experience, it's going to take a while. It's not going to be something you can achieve overnight. Someone that I know who also experience the passing of a loved one at a similar time to me said something to me the other day and I thought it was really amazing. She just said to me, I've just focused on doing the things I love because I guess you know that that's what's going to make, make you happy and make that other person. That would make them happy. Just focus on doing the things that aren't really an effort to do, that you can push yourself to do, things that you enjoy. There's no point kind of wasting time. But I want to jump back into one of those things that I mentioned before, and that's the role of anger whilst you're grieving. It might be a surprise
生活，这需要一段时间。这不是你能在一夜之间实现的事情。我认识的一个人，在与我差不多的时间也经历了亲人的离世，前几天对我说了一句话，我觉得太棒了。她对我说，我只是专注于做我喜欢的事情，因为我想你知道那会让你开心，也会让另一个人开心。那会让他们开心。只专注于做那些不需要付出太多努力就能去做的事情，那些你可以逼自己去做的事情，你喜欢的事情。浪费时间没有什么意义。但我回到我之前提到的一件事情上，那就是悲伤时愤怒的作用。这可能会让你感到惊讶
to you to see that I'm talking about anger, but anger is essentially, our brain protesting against something we're experiencing, that is perceived to be unjust or frustrating. And that's definitely going to be your mindset if you've lost someone or something. When you're grieving, you're kind of beset by a number of really confusing and stressful experiences. And very often it's perceived as unfair and really out of your control. And when things are out of our control, we want to put systems or understandings around that experience that allow us to place blame, allow us to direct anger. And in this sense, anger and grief go hand in hand. Anger provides a way of expressing that hopelessness and powerlessness and despair that you might be experiencing if you've lost one.
看到我在谈论愤怒，但愤怒本质上是我们的大脑在对我们正在经历的、被认为是不公正或令人沮丧的事情进行抗议。如果你失去了某人或某物，这绝对会成为你的心态。当你悲伤时，你会被许多非常混乱和压力重重的经历所困扰。而且很多时候，这被认为是不公平的，而且完全超出了你的控制。当事情超出了我们的控制，我们希望围绕这种经历建立系统或理解，让我们能够归咎责任，让我们能够引导愤怒。从这个意义上说，愤怒和悲伤是齐头并进的。愤怒提供了一种表达你可能正在经历的无助、无力和绝望的方式，如果你失去了某人。
And I've lost someone. And I guess the consequence of this is that it. may seem as though, you know, if you have someone in your life who's lost someone recently, it might seem that they're hostile or bitter towards you or other people around you, but it's important to look past this and recognise that anger might be an expression of a deeper psychological state of one in which that person doesn't feel like they have control, they feel frustrated, they feel like the world is unjust. And the only, you know, rational feeling that their brain can kind of correspond with that is to feel angry and to kind of lash out. And I guess that's a really
而我失去了某人。我想其后果是它。可能看起来，你知道的，如果你生命中有人最近失去了亲人，他们可能对你或你周围其他人表现出敌意或痛苦，但重要的是要看穿这一点，并认识到愤怒可能是更深层次心理状态的一种表达，在这种状态下，这个人觉得他们无法控制，他们感到沮丧，他们觉得世界是不公正的。而他们的大脑唯一能与之对应的理性感觉，你知道的，就是感到愤怒并进行猛烈抨击。我想这是一个非常
good segue into the stages of grief. So there are widely believed to be five stages of grief. And they don't just apply to loss or death. I think they're often extrapolated to also cover things like heartbreak. I talked about this in my breakup episode. Listen to it if you want to. But the stages of grief. They are denial, anger, which we've talked about, bargaining, depression, and acceptance. The cherry on top. They're often misunderstood. They aren't always linear. You know, once you pass one, it's not like you're done with that, you know, door closed on denial, chapter closed on anger. They're not consecutive. Sometimes you can jump from, you know, back a few steps, forward a few steps, but each stage has its rightful place in accepting the loss of someone
很好地过渡到悲伤的各个阶段。人们普遍认为悲伤有五个阶段。它们不仅适用于失去或死亡。我认为它们经常被外推以涵盖诸如心碎之类的事情。我在我的分手剧集里谈过这个。如果你想听的话，可以去听一下。但悲伤的阶段。它们是：否认、我们已经讨论过的愤怒、讨价还价、抑郁和接受。锦上添花。它们经常被误解。它们并不总是线性的。你知道，一旦你度过了某一个阶段，并不意味着你就完成了那个阶段，你知道的，对否认关上了门，对愤怒合上了章节。它们不是连续的。有时你可以从，你知道的，倒退几步，前进几步，但每个阶段在接受某人的离世方面都有其应有的位置
in accepting death. So denial, this can look like avoidance, procrastination, forgetting, maybe you're easily distracted and it can feel like shock, numbness, confusion, shutting down. This is often associated with those first few months after the passing of a loved one. It's really hard to believe. You know, you've spent your whole life or a big part of a of your life with the knowledge and the comfort that they're around and that they exist. And then suddenly reality is different. So it's really, you know, really common for people to not have really processed it to feel like they're fine, to be keeping busy and doing mindless behaviours because they don't
在接受死亡方面。所以是否认，这看起来可能像逃避、拖延、健忘，也许你很容易分心，它可能会让人感觉像震惊、麻木、困惑、崩溃。这通常与亲人离世后的头几个月有关。这真的很难相信。你知道的，你的一生或你生命中的很大一部分都带着他们就在身边并且存在的知识和安慰。然后突然之间现实变了。所以人们没有真正处理好它，感觉自己很好，保持忙碌并做出毫无意义的行为，这是非常普遍的，因为他们并不
really want to face the reality of their circumstances. The next stage is anger. We've talked about this, that frustration, that resentment, rage, feeling. out of control, you might be getting into arguments or increasing, you know, increasing aggressive behaviour or use of alcohol. Things like death are really hard to, they're impossible to control, impossible to control. And once someone's gone, you can't get them back. And that is so fucking frustrating because everything else, most things in life, you have some control and say over. So, That's when we start to feel angry, angry at our circumstances.
真的想面对他们处境的现实。下一个阶段是愤怒。我们已经讨论过了，那种沮丧、那种怨恨、愤怒、感觉失控，你可能会陷入争执，或者增加，你知道的，增加攻击性行为或酒精的使用。死亡之类的事情真的很难，它们是不可能控制的，不可能控制的。一旦有人走了，你就无法让他们回来。这真是太他妈的令人沮丧了，因为其他一切，生活中的大多数事情，你都有一定的控制权和发言权。所以，这就是我们开始感到愤怒的时候，对我们的处境感到愤怒。
Then comes bargaining. And this can look like, you know, trying to predict the future and assuming the worst, thinking or saying things like I should have or if only I'd done this, sense of guilt and shame, fear, anxiety. It's pretty terrible. Bargaining is that sense of like, well, if I'd just done this, if I do this, then this won't happen again. And it's delusional, essentially.
然后是讨价还价。这看起来可能像，你知道的，试图预测未来并做最坏的打算，想着或说着诸如“我本应该”或“要是我早点这么做了就好了”之类的话，内疚和羞耻感、恐惧、焦虑。这真是太糟糕了。讨价还价就像是一种感觉，“好吧，如果我刚刚做了这个，如果我这样做了，那么就不会发生这种事了。”这本质上是妄想。
It's your brain once again trying to find. comfort in a really uncomfortable situation and it's often followed by depression anger and bargaining are followed by depression because when you realize there's nothing you can do god of course you're going to feel absolutely terrible of course you're going to feel sad and hopeless and disappointed overwhelmed this is when i think a lot of the symptoms that people usually associate with grief really start to take hold the crying the appetite changes changes to sleep, you know, the increased use of alcohol or drugs, you know, the depression. It's depression. That's what we often associate grief with, even though it is a lot more nuanced
这又是你试图在非常不舒服的处境中寻找安慰的大脑，而这通常伴随着抑郁。愤怒和讨价还价之后是抑郁，因为当你意识到自己无能为力时，天哪，你当然会感觉绝对糟糕，你当然会感到悲伤、绝望、失望、不知所措。我认为正是在这个时候，人们通常与悲伤联系在一起的许多症状才真正开始占据主导地位，哭泣、食欲改变、睡眠改变，你知道的，增加酒精或药物的使用，你知道的，抑郁。这就是抑郁。这就是我们经常将悲伤联系在一起的东西，尽管它远比这更微妙
and texture than that. But let's light at the end of the tunnel, as always. After moving through these phases, we do often get to a point of acceptance, of accepting reality for what it is, of accepting the state of life for what it is. People leave, people go, and it doesn't mean that the love that they had and the love that they had for you and for others disappears. It's still all around us, that energy never goes away that existed at some point and you can still feel the warmth of that if you're calling it. And I think that's where I'm at right now. And, you know, of course things change, but acceptance feels like self-referenced. Acceptance feels like self-referral compassion. It feels like wisdom. You feel that you're in the moment and you're able to be
并且比那更有质感。但正如往常一样，隧道尽头总有光亮。在经历这些阶段之后，我们确实经常达到一个接受的阶段，接受现实本来的样子，接受生活的状态本来的样子。人们离开，人们走了，这并不意味着他们曾经拥有的爱，以及他们对你对其他人拥有的爱就消失了。它仍然在我们周围，那种曾经存在过的能量永远不会消失，如果你呼唤它，你仍然能感受到它的温暖。我想这就是我现在的状态。而且，你知道的，事情当然会改变，但接受感觉就像是对自己的指引。接受感觉就像是自我关怀。它感觉像是智慧。你会觉得你活在当下，并且能够
vulnerable like I'm being right now, I guess, and tolerate your emotions. It shows that you've adapted, you're able to cope and respond skillfully to the situation that you've been put into. It all comes down, I think, when we talk about these stages of grief, a big question people often ask you know how often or how long does grief tend to last is it a six-month thing it's interesting when we think about this in terms of the loss of like a partner like when you go through a breakup there's this like anecdote that the amount of time it takes for you to get over them is half the amount of time that you dated you know if you dated for a year it'll take six months that kind of thing it's just ridiculous because grief is something that stays with you it might be
脆弱，就像我现在这样，我想，并且能够容忍你的情绪。这表明你已经适应了，你能够熟练地应对你所处的情况并作出反应。这一切归结起来，我想，当我们谈论悲伤的这几个阶段时，人们经常会问的一个大问题是，你知道的，悲伤通常会持续多久，是六个月的事吗？当我们从失去伴侣的角度来思考这个问题时，这很有趣，比如当你经历分手时，有一个传言说，你忘掉他们所需的时间是你约会时间的一半，你知道的，如果你约会了一年，就会花六个月，诸如此类。这太荒谬了，因为悲伤是伴随你左右的东西，它可能会
go away. It might go away for some time. Life might feel really great and I don't think it's something to be scared of that grief doesn't leave. Grief is a reminder that you loved really deeply. If you didn't, you wouldn't be feeling this way and I think that's why it's important. And grief lasts, you know, might last, might last a lifetime. Might not be that long. But it is an important kind of feeling or sensation and a reminder. that you wouldn't be able to feel this way if you didn't care as deeply. And although it might feel really tricky and hard right now, it does get better. I know that sounds so annoying, but that is the cruelest and the best thing about time
走开。它可能会离开一段时间。生活可能会感觉非常棒，我不认为悲伤没有离开是一件可怕的事情。悲伤提醒着你曾深深地爱过。如果你没有，你就不会有这种感觉，我想这就是为什么它很重要。悲伤会持续，你知道的，可能会持续，可能会持续一生。也许没那么久。但它是一种重要的感觉或知觉，是一个提醒。如果你没有那么在乎，你就不会有这种感觉。虽然现在感觉可能真的很棘手和艰难，但它会好起来的。我知道这听起来很烦人，但这就是时间最残酷也是最美好的地方
is that it always passes. And you always reach a better state. But in order to get there, I guess there are some things that you can do, some practices, some skills that are really good to take on. For me, one of my personal practices, something that I do is every time I think about the people, the person that I've lost, I just hold that thought consciously in my mind for a little while.
在于它总是会流逝。你总是会达到一个更好的状态。但为了到达那里，我想有一些事情你可以做，有一些练习，一些真正值得接受的技能。对我来说，我个人的做法之一，我做的一件事是，每当我想起我失去的人、那个人时，我在脑海中会有意识地把那个想法保留一会儿。
I just sit there and I think, you know, I've thought about them. I've had this sensation. I'm just going to hold on to that for a little while and send them love. Send their memory love. I don't know why it just makes me. feel a lot better. When I think about this person that I lost, I just make sure that I take a few
我只是坐在那里，我想，你知道的，我想到了他们。我有了这种感觉。我要把这个保留一会儿，然后向他们发送爱。向他们的记忆发送爱。我不知道为什么它只是让我。感觉好多了。当我想到我失去的这个人时，我确保我花了几
seconds just to say hi and just to send them a positive message. There are other things that aren't as spiritual or as weird as that. I know that sounds a bit strange, but whatever it takes, especially in those early months, establishing a good routine, scheduling pleasant events and promoting self-care activities. That is so. important. Things like limiting alcohol intake, daily exercise, making sure you're seeing a psychologist if you need to, which you know, everyone can kind of benefit from. Although those practices might not feel like they're helping day to day, in the long run you'll find that you're not as stuck in that period of grief, you know, using alcohol or trying to avoid
秒钟只是打个招呼，只是给他们发一条积极的信息。还有一些事情没有那么精神化或那么怪异。我知道这听起来有点奇怪，但无论付出什么代价，特别是在头几个月里，建立一个良好的规律，安排令人愉快的活动并促进自我照顾活动。那是如此。重要。诸如限制酒精摄入量、日常锻炼、确保在需要时去看心理医生，你知道的，每个人都可以从中受益。尽管这些练习可能感觉对日常生活没有帮助，但从长远来看，你会发现你并没有那么深陷于悲伤的时期中，你知道的，借酒浇愁或试图逃避
feelings of sadness never really works, they just come back stronger. And I think that also comes to the next point, which is prepare yourself to face new and difficult situations and challenge unhelpful thinking. I think it's really important and what I found important when I was grieving was to be able to see those reactions like guilt and anger and identify them for what they were, which was a reaction to a situation that I didn't understand. That was hard. That was uncomfortable and that was unpleasant.
悲伤的感觉从来没有真正起过作用，它们只会卷土重来，而且更强烈。我想这也引出了下一部分，那就是准备好面对新的困难情况并挑战无益的想法。我认为这非常重要，我在悲伤时发现重要的事情是能够看到内疚和愤怒等这些反应，并认清它们的本质，即对我不理解的情况的反应。那是艰难的。那是令人不舒服的，也是令人不快的。
And ask yourself these questions, you know, what would your loved one tell you to do if they were still here? What would they like you to do? Would they want to see you like this? What are the alternatives to what you've thought? Where is the evidence of what you've thought? What are your favorite memories of them? Turn that script and make it one that's positive.
问自己这些问题，你知道的，如果你的挚爱还在这里，他们会让你做什么？他们希望你做什么？他们想看到你这样吗？你所想的事情有哪些替代方案？你所想的证据在哪里？你最喜欢他们什么记忆？扭转剧本，把它变成积极的。
And decide to really focus on, on not so much the positives, because I know that sounds so, you know, fucked. Like someone's passed away, how you're meant to focus on the positives. But I guess really prod those emotions, prod those negative thinking, those negative thoughts of, you know, this is going to last forever. This is the worst thing that's ever happened to me. I'm never going to feel happy again. and ask yourself, is that really the truth? Is that really how it's going to be? Because I think that the answer deep down and that you know is that it's not going to be like that. Some other just things that I've learned, don't make any major irreversible decisions in the proceeding of, sorry,
并决定真正专注于，不是那么多的积极面，因为我知道这听起来太，你知道的，操蛋了。就像有人去世了，你怎么能被要求专注于积极面呢。但我想真正戳穿那些情绪，戳穿那些消极的想法，那些“这会永远持续下去”、“这是我经历过的最糟糕的事情”、“我再也不会感到快乐了”的消极想法。并问自己，这真的是事实吗？事情真的会是这样吗？因为我认为内心深处的答案以及你知道的是，事情不会是那样的。其他一些我学到的事情，在接下来的几个月里，不要做出任何重大且不可逆转的决定，对不起，
in the following months after someone's passed away. I got a tattoo. I love it. And I don't regret it. probably not the best decision. You know, there's, I guess when you feel like things are out of your control, sometimes you want to just reinsert control by doing crazy, spontaneous things. Maybe just wait. Just have a think about it first. And maybe identify some other possible solutions to why you're feeling the need to do that. Determine what's actually going to positively influence you right now,
在某人去世后的几个月里。我纹身了。我很喜欢它。我不后悔。可能不是最好的决定。你知道的，我猜当你觉得事情超出了你的控制时，有时你只想通过做疯狂、自发的事情来重新获得控制。也许再等等。先考虑一下。也许找出你觉得有必要这样做的其他可能解决方案。确定什么才是真正会对你产生积极影响的事情，
surround yourself with beautiful people, beautiful friends. That was the thing that really got me through. I had some amazing friends. My friend Kate, she, yeah, she just, I just remember her saying the right things and I'm glad that she was there. And a lot of my friends, they really stood up for me in that time. It was really hard. You know, there were other things going on. Like I said, was in a pretty bad relationship that probably wasn't right for me, dealing with stuff in my sharehouse and border closures wasn't able to be around my family. So the things that really meant a lot to me was establishing those routines,
让自己身边环绕着美丽的人、美丽的朋友。正是这件事真正让我度过了难关。我有一些很棒的朋友。我的朋友凯特，她，是的，她只是，我只记得她说了正确的话，我很高兴她当时在那里。我的很多朋友在那段时期真的挺身而出。那真的很艰难。你知道的，还有其他事情在发生。就像我说的，当时处在一个可能不太适合我的糟糕关系中，处理我合租房里的事情，由于边境关闭无法待在家人身边。所以对我意义重大的事情是建立那些日常规律，
remembering the love I had for that person and surrounding myself with the good people that I did have. I think we're going to end things there, but thank you so much for listening. This was a really personal episode. I've been saying that on a lot of episodes recently. Maybe I need to take a bit of a chill pill. Become too vulnerable.
记住我对那个人的爱，并让我身边环绕着我确实拥有的好人。我想我们要在这里结束了，但非常感谢你们的收听。这是一期非常私人的节目。我最近在很多节目里都这么说。也许我需要稍微冷静一下。变得太脆弱了。
It's been a year of the problem. podcast. I feel like I'm talking to friends now. But in all seriousness, this was something I did really want to talk about. And I hope that if you are going through something similar right now, I'm sending you so much love, it is really, really hard. But I kind of ask you to sit with those feelings and I don't know I guess question question some of your emotional responses remind yourself that if you didn't love them as much if it wasn't that unconditional love you wouldn't be feeling this way and that love doesn't just disappear because their physical body does I know that's getting a little bit spiritual but I guess the thing with grief is that it is part of the human
这是播客的一年问题。我觉得我现在的感觉就像是在和朋友聊天。但说真的，这确实是我真的很想谈论的事情。我希望如果你现在也正经历类似的事情，我向你送去满满的爱，这真的非常非常难。但我有点要求你去面对这些感受，我不知道，我想我是在质疑、质疑你的一些情绪反应，提醒自己，如果你不是那么爱他们，如果那不是无条件的爱，你就不会有这种感觉，而且这种爱不会仅仅因为他们的肉体消失而消失。我知道这听起来有点精神上的东西，但我想关于悲伤的事情是它是人类的一部分
experience it is like any other emotion it's complicated it's nuanced it's confusing but it serves a really important purpose, and I think that purpose is to remind us that we do love deeply. We can have deep connections with others, and when they're gone, it hurts, but that doesn't mean that they didn't live a beautiful life and that they didn't leave an impact on you. So, yeah, if you're really struggling, I'm really sorry to hear that, but I hope this episode provided you some guidance, made you feel better about things. And I'm sending you love for those who haven't lost someone and who are just listening in. Well, thank you so much, and I hope that you enjoyed this as well.
体验，它就像任何其他情绪一样，它很复杂，它很微妙，它令人困惑，但它有着非常重要的目的，我认为这个目的就是提醒我们，我们确实深深地爱着。我们可以与他人建立深厚的联系，当他们离开时，这很痛，但这并不意味着他们没有过上美丽的生活，也没有对你产生影响。所以，是的，如果你真的在苦苦挣扎，听到这个我真的很遗憾，但我希望这一集能为你提供一些指导，让你感觉好一点。我向那些没有失去亲人只是在收听的人送去爱。好吧，非常感谢，我希望你也很喜欢这个。
As always, if you feel the need, if you feel the calling to, if you feel called to, please leave the podcast a review on either Spotify or Apple Podcasts. It helps the podcast grow. It is just me here sharing personal things about my life. So I love to always see new reviews and see that there is a community growing around this and receiving your messages. So thank you so much. and thank you for listening. Have a beautiful week, beautiful people. Hey, what's good, y'all?
和往常一样，如果你觉得有必要，如果你觉得有这种召唤，如果你觉得被召唤，请在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上给播客留下评论。这有助于播客的成长。这里只有我一个人分享我生活的私人事情。所以我总是喜欢看到新的评论，看到周围有一个社群在成长，并收到你们的信息。所以非常感谢你们。谢谢你们的收听。祝大家拥有美好的一周，美好的人们。嘿，最近怎么样，大家？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
您正在收听由您喜爱的治疗师兼主持人克尔·盖姆斯带来的《吃一堑长一智》。这个空间关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全、却又真实坦诚的对话，但与你对话的是一位深谙此道的持证专业人士。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就非得这么做。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上收听《吃一堑长一智》。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个惯犯骗手时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客，保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。